my name is David Bob and I served as
director of the alan p Kirby jr. center
for constitutional studies and
citizenship hillsdale college it's my
pleasure this morning to welcome you to
this lecture part of the first
principles on First Fridays lecture
series this is a monthly series that
addresses topics of significant and
timely historical political and economic
subjects we are grateful today that this
lecture series which bears the name the
mrs. Walter our burger first principles
on first Friday's lecture has been
brought about as a result of her
generosity mrs. Berger lives in Michigan
and she has a number of grandchildren
that have served in the United States
military including Earl Pettis a 2008
alumnus of Hillsdale College who has
recently returned from duty in
Afghanistan today we are honored to have
as our speaker general Ronald Burgess
director of the Defense Intelligence
Agency in a distinguished army career of
more than 40 years general Burgess has
established a record of exemplary
service to his country for which we
should all be grateful general Burgess
and his wife Marta who I'm pleased to
say is here with us today are the proud
parents of five children two of whom we
at Hillsdale are proud to say our
graduates of the College the academic
year has just started and it's a bracing
thought to realize that the college
freshman who just showed up at the at
Hillsdale and around the country were
just eight years old when our nation was
attacked on September for September 11
2001 too young to understand its full
meaning and yet too old to be oblivious
to it those young people have been
impacted by the terrorist acts of 9-11
indelibly as we all have been more than
1,300 children were orphaned on that day
a day in which nearly 300 nearly 3,000
lives were taken let us pause now for a
moment of silence and remembrance of
those victims
thank you hillsdale college junior
Caroline Forsyth the politics major is
interning this semester with the
American Legislative Exchange Council
this is as part of her participation in
the semester long Washington Hillsdale
internship program which brings
hillsdale college undergraduates to
Washington for study and work here in
the nation's capital it's a program that
is nearly 40 years old and I'm pleased
to say that in keeping with hillsdale's
tradition that students introduce our
speakers I will now call upon Caroline
to introduce general Burgess Caroline
welcome lieutenant general Ronald L
Burgess jr. is the director of the
Defense Intelligence Agency and
commander of the joint functional
component command in a career spanning
nearly 40 years he has received numerous
awards and decorations including the
defense Distinguished Service Medal the
defense superior service medal the
Legion of Merit the meritorious service
medal a joint service Commendation Medal
the Army Commendation Medal the army
achievement medal and the NATO medal
commissioned in military intelligence
for the Auburn University ROTC program
he earned a Master of Science degree in
education from the University of
Southern California and a master
military arts and science from the US
army command and general staff college
today general burgers will be speaking
on the timely and pressing topic
America's war on terror please join me
in welcoming general Burgess
thanks for the very good introduction
well done it is a great honor for me to
be here today and spend time with you I
have some prepared remarks that I will
move through and then I have been told
that we will do question and answer and
I will handle that here from the podium
during that time but as I prepared for
my visit here today as was pointed out
by David I couldn't help but remember
hillsdale's motto pursuing truth and
defending Liberty and that's a fitting
place for me to begin my remarks because
those words reflect the mission of the
men and women of the Defense
Intelligence Agency our intelligence
work is aimed at preventing strategic
surprise by uncovering the truth about
current and potential adversaries
military intentions and capabilities and
we do this in defense of the nation it's
just a few hours ago i presided over dia
ceremony in honor of the seven agency
employees that we lost in the Pentagon
on 911 now I don't presume to speak for
anyone else but I along with others find
it hard to believe that a decade has
passed since that tragic day we also
cannot help but reflect on how the event
affected the lives of so many of us in
this room today both directly and
indirectly as we think back to that day
it is important to remember that those
killed in New York at the Pentagon and
in Shanksville Pennsylvania that of the
three thousand that David mentioned that
more than a little more than ten percent
of those folks of those number killed on
that day were citizens of countries
other than the United States such losses
remind us that terrorism is a threat not
just to the United States but to all
nations
in an increasingly interconnected world
both culturally financially with
instantaneous information and attack
against one is in a very real sense and
attack against others the conflicts over
the past decade has affected all of us
while also teaching us some important
lessons some were new and some we
learned again the hard way I'd like to
share with you today three general
observations I'll start with what I
think is a defining characteristic for a
shared operating environment in today's
increasingly networked world we have
entered into a period of accelerating
change one that carries significant
consequences from military and
intelligence professionals fighter
pilots have a saying that when it comes
to a dogfight speed is life I find that
is increasingly true for those of us
that serve in the military and in the
intelligence professions we only have to
look at the history being made across
North Africa in the Middle East today
what began in Tunisia last December has
left few countries in the region
untouched or the citizens of those
countries unchanged like a long-dormant
geological fault line jolted by an
earthquake history throughout the region
is on the move the so-called Arab Spring
has evolved into the hot arab summer in
Yemen Libya and Syria no matter your
sources of information if you can
predict with confidence the full impact
of what we are seeing occur in the
Middle East today we also must be
mindful that the 21st century social
media tools such as Facebook and Twitter
do not necessarily guarantee good
outcomes history is full of examples of
revolutions that fail to produce
positive change the experience of the
French Revolution led some to observe
revolutions devour their children but
the patterns and cycles that once took
years or months in previous revolutions
in history we now see unfolding in weeks
days and hours with you to providing
near real-time coverage of the jasmine
revolution the Arab Spring and serious
efforts to crush dissent the revolution
indeed is being televised and we see the
challenge it presents for participants
and observers alike time after time we
have seen the awareness and
decision-making by governments in those
countries outpaced by highly
decentralized in networks citizens and
for other nations on the outside looking
in trying to understand the course of
events and implications it has been a
very humbling experience with citizens
over the world the world over able to
communicate in text and video in
real-time the speed of events has
compressed the time available for
decision-making and intelligence
professionals are now expected to
collect information and deliver analysis
on the events nearly in real-time as the
crisis is unfolding earlier in my career
intelligence professionals wrote reports
and delivered them the next day today's
history is being streamed in real-time
and intelligence reports delivered the
next day make me a historian
transnational terrorist groups also have
access to the same information
technologies including computers digital
cameras thumb drives and publishing and
video editing software some of those
groups have proven themselves to be
highly adaptive and resilient learning
organizations and increasingly they are
reacting to events learning lessons
networking reorienting and
reconstituting themselves after setbacks
more quickly than ever highly adaptive
we have seen these groups
employee new tactics we saw the
so-called underwear bomber the plot to
destroy airplanes with bombs disguised
in printer cartridges and we see Press
reports now claiming that terrorist
interest in surgically implanting bombs
inside people under enormous pressure
terrorist groups have learned how to
leverage the internet for defensive and
offensive purposes and the technologies
they employ accelerate the speed at
which they operate while also magnifying
their reach to new supporters such as
independent or lone wolf actors prone to
self-radicalization and subsequent
terrorist acts we see that in the
efforts by al-qaeda in the Arabian
Peninsula to create an english-language
magazine to recruit new members and
inspire attacks and the shooting at fort
hood texas reminds us that not even our
own ranks are immune to self radicalized
individuals we have seen the speed at
which decentralized relatively flat
networks can operate react and adapt and
that is a challenge for institutions
built on vertical top-down decision
making such as many of the military
institutions and government agencies
headquartered in the Washington DC
region fortunately we have adjusted
significantly to this accelerating rate
of change and that takes me to my second
observation in order to be successful
against terrorism in today's environment
it is imperative to fuse intelligence
and operations to the maximum extent
possible over the last 10 years we have
pushed a lot of intelligence capability
forward in direct support of our
military forces in Iraq and Afghanistan
and that includes in support of allies
who are or who have been engaged with us
in those theaters because of the speed
of events on the battlefield dia has
forward deployed more analyst and other
professionals to the battlefield than at
any time in its nearly 50-year history
and frankly it is transformed dia from a
garrison agency headquarters in
Washington that historically supported
small deployments of personnel into a
globally deployed agency supported by a
headquarters in Washington in previous
conflicts dia would conduct much of its
work in Washington and push the
information forward to the battlefield
by the time the intelligence arrived
sometimes it was useful and timely other
times it was not that old construct had
no chance of surviving under the demands
of the modern battlefield against
insurgencies and terrorists and so in
the years since the 911 attacks dia has
deployed increasing numbers of personnel
and today that number of ranges in the
area of about 850 personnel or so give
or take that are there to provide direct
support to our military commanders and
troops on the ground and provide the
best possible advice to policymakers
back here in Washington dia pays those
intelligence professionals we equip them
we train them and we support them but in
a day to day since those dia
professionals work for the military
commanders and the troops that they are
for deployed with in addition we have
found the most success when we place our
personnel alongside those of other
intelligence agencies and other
intelligence disciplines the effect has
been profound different intelligence
disciplines often tip or q1 another
leading to increased collection and a
more detailed and more useful analysis
moreover all of that work is much more
attuned to the needs of the military
commander and the troops on the ground
our people are participating in
commanders daily briefings they absorbed
the commander's needs and work within
the staffs battle rhythm not the rhythm
someplace else like Washington DC the
intelligence we provide is no longer a
once-a-day Morning Report now it is a
constant stream of knowledge and
advantage that informs
effects or even shapes a commander's
decision-making in real time former
secretary of defense robert gates put it
this way there's been a revolution in
both intelligence collection and the
application of intelligence to
operations the fusion of intelligence
and operations in iraq and afghanistan
not just with the Special Forces but
with the conventional forces is
something that 10 years ago people
wouldn't have believed possible the
standard for Defense Intelligence has
shifted considerably in the decades
since 911 no longer is acceptable for
intelligence to merely support
operations what we are seeing on the
battlefield today is that good
intelligence drives operations that is
what we aim for because that is what
today's strategic environment requires
yet no matter how proficient we become
we recognize that success cannot be
achieved in isolation while there will
always be a place in a role for
unilateral operations the larger
campaign against terrorism requires
cooperation among nations which takes me
to my third observation more than ever
successful operations against terrorism
are multinational not so much by choice
but by necessity the threat posed by
terrorism today transcends national
borders to form an effective response
robust counterterrorism operations
require increased cooperation and shared
responsibility among international
partners we're there while there were
always be limits we have made great
progress in the recent years now I've
been in intelligence professional for a
long time and I have to tell you that we
are sharing intelligence to a degree and
with partners that I would never would
have thought possible earlier in my
career and that is the key point I want
to make with you when crisis arise that
is not the time to start building
relationships there
won't be time events will be moving too
quickly we have to start well in advance
years and decades what we are doing
today with our allies building trust
opening up pipelines for information
sharing prepares us for crisis or
conflicts that we may not even be able
to conceive of right now and that
two-way education among nations is
important at this point in history more
than ever the problems and challenges we
face today are bigger and more complex
that can then can be solved by any one
country or only by one alliance many of
the challenges we face today confront
many nations and require that we all
work together whether nations are
jointly conducting humanitarian
assistant operations counter piracy
maritime patrols peacekeeping missions
or engaged in counterinsurgency
operations increasingly we need to all
find this to strengthen the trust that
military and intelligence relationships
require the terrorist groups that we
face today are highly complex highly
adaptive and very resilient al-qaeda has
taken some very hard hits recently and
is currently under a lot of pressure
especially at the most senior levels
that having been said we are watching
today how that pressure transforms the
movement especially within the regional
affiliate groups such as al-qaida in the
Arabian Peninsula or AQAP we have
learned over the last 10 years that one
no one nation can achieve success alone
we increase our collective odds of
success significantly by working
together regardless of the type of
mission each partner nation brings
something unique to the fight whether
that be different skill sets different
access a novel approach or technique or
perhaps a diversity of language or
analytical capability
and that's good against the problem sets
that we face whether it be al Qaeda the
Taliban or another terrorist group
collectively we need every different
kind of tool we can employ to get at
these heart problems and hard targets
some of which are very much intertwined
with local tribal ethnic or religious
conflicts that level of cooperation is
needed today because many of today's
terrorist adversaries international
criminal or proliferation networks or
maritime pirates seek advantage by
hiding in operating in the gaps and
seams between nations between alliances
between borders and in govern areas
beyond the central government's control
defeating these kinds of threats will
require greater levels of information
sharing and cooperation among nations
than we have ever seen before by working
together we can all close those gaps and
seams and by doing so increase our
collective security well we have seen in
experienced in the decade of war since
911 represents a new world for those of
us that where the military uniform and
who are called upon to operate in
today's evolving environment dia has
been at war for 10 years more than
two-thirds of our employees today came
aboard after the 911 attack they have
known nothing except providing wartime
intelligence to commanders and
policymakers by virtue of their
experience their hard work their
commitment they have transformed dia
into a much forward deployed agency that
drives military operations like never
before that is why we need the most
talented students to consider a career
in uniform or as a civilian intelligence
professional we need students today to
study foreign languages to study foreign
cultures to study political science to
study history all of which Hillsdale is
good at
at this very moment many of our soldiers
sailors airmen Marines and intelligence
professionals are working side by side
on the battlefield they are sharing risk
and facing dangers together they deserve
the very best intelligence support that
we can give it give them we owe it to
them to recruit the best minds into our
profession to ask the hard questions to
challenge ourselves to challenge one
another and our traditional ways of
approaching problems most of all they
deserve our ability to recognize when
old methods of operating no longer apply
and when new approaches and solutions
are required let me close with a few
words from the Secretary of Defense I
believe it reflects in a very real way
the progress we have made in the fight
against transnational terrorism during a
flight to visit our troops in
Afghanistan Secretary of Defense Panetta
said that now is the moment now is the
moment to put maximum pressure on them
because I do believe that if we continue
this effort that we can really crippled
al Qaeda as a threat he could make that
statement only because of the tremendous
amount of work that has been done within
this government the Department of
Defense the intelligence community and
with our allies and partners around the
world but at the same time it also
signals that what we can achieve in the
weeks months and years ahead by
maintaining a sharp focus on our mission
and seeing the job through to the end we
owe that to the families and friends who
lost loved ones to ten years ago and
those that have lost loved ones and
friends since that time we owe that to
the men and women that are serving today
we owe that to the citizens of our
country thank you I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you did you make the distinction
between the Central Intelligence Agency
and the DIA in terms of responsibility
and what you do and perhaps a little
more information about the personnel
splits of military and civilian and
budget of your agency I'll come to the
I'll take the second part of your
question first and take the first part
and let me just say up front on the
questions because I say this when I do
public speaking and I appreciate your
understanding the situation which i find
myself as I tell people quite often I've
been doing intelligence work for a long
time and so there are times I wonder in
my own head about what I know whether
that's classified or whether it's not
that shouldn't impact you you'll to ask
whatever question you want and it's my
job to figure out how to answer the
question it might guarantee to you is I
will figure out a way to answer your
question even if you board Iran one that
may get me in trouble but the defense
intelligence agency right now my agency
has authorized about about 18,000
personnel inside my agency and that
makeup is split right now between
sixty-five percent civilian and
thirty-five percent that wear the
uniform of that 18,000 and you know as I
tell people without getting into the the
classified portion on it right now I
have been provided the resources in
terms of the dollars and budget to do
the mission that I've been
so we're we're in pretty good shape not
going to say I'm not going to fight for
more but at the end of the day I've got
enough resources do the mission that
I've been given when you look at the
Defense Intelligence Agency and compare
us to CIA for example in this case first
of all you need to remember that inside
the the Department of Defense there are
parts of the intelligence community that
exists there such as myself dia NSA NGA
I'm sorry National Security Agency
national geospatial Agency and the
National Reconnaissance Office and
myself that make that up and as such I
am what is referred to as a Combat
Support Agency inside the Department of
Defense and so therefore my particular
responsibility is to provide
intelligence to the Secretary of Defense
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs and the
full myriad of commanders running from
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs through
the combatant commanders such as the
combatant commander for Central Command
which is the region most people are
normally focus on there with general
mattis a US Central Command in Tampa
focused on that part of the world but we
have combatant commanders that that have
responsibility worldwide and so my
responsibility along with my agency is
to provide intelligence support not only
to those folks in uniform but to also
provide support to folks that do
policymaking in the defense realm inside
the Department of Defense and others
represented inside the interagency
process process to include ensuring that
I present what I would call a defense
view on intelligence in terms of how we
look at the facts because let me let me
talk about the Central Intelligence
Agency for just a second in terms of
their responsibilities they also are
responsible for providing intelligence
support to the United States in terms of
what they do they also like the Defense
Intelligence Agency
they are a what we call an all source
analytical agency and they also execute
other operations in terms of what they
do on that but one of the primary things
that they do is provide that all source
intelligence what we mean in the
intelligence community when we say all
source for people that don't do
intelligence work there are a lot of
intelligence disciplines out there for
example human intelligence that's
basically doing what some people might
refer to is you know going out and
having a human collector some some want
to call a spy you know with people that
do that kind of work you have folks that
just go out and do normal Intel
reporting from a human perspective in
the day-to-day course of their duties
you have signals intelligence that is
that information that we gather by
collecting signals you know from the air
and analyzing those signals and that's
called signals intelligence you've got
imagery intelligence you know pictures
things that are taken by by things that
aren't on the ground whether that be in
the sky or other ways imagery toes so
you've got a lot of different but only
CIA and dia along with the State
Department with a very small group so
really CIA and Dia do what we call all
source analysis so when one of my
analyst analysts published an article on
Afghanistan likessee I would they take
imagery intelligence signals
intelligence human intelligence open
source intelligence ossett as we call it
because quite honestly you can get some
reasonably good information sometimes
from the press you have to consider the
source as I say in some of that you know
as you take a look at a bit and all
source analyst brings in all the
different pipes and analyzes that and
comes out with their assessment then for
policymakers but both of us do do that
type of work my work is primarily
focused on supporting military and doing
defense while CIA provides it to a
auto group across the United States
government and for the nation and while
their specific focus is not defense they
would report on other things such as
political and economic and other things
that I would not necessarily be in a
sweet spot for me sir general thank you
for coming my question is is maybe well
I'll just throw it out from a defense
perspective would you say that the
greater threat to our national security
and our way of life comes from that the
Muslim Brotherhood or the nation-state
of Libya under moammar qaddafi I you
know I'm not going to parse in piece of
the way you've asked what I mean
currently we we're a nation as I said
you know in my remarks that have been
under attack we've been at war over the
past 10 years in fact the fight actually
started before that you know you can go
back in history but at least if you go
back to nineteen ninety eight where bin
Laden issued his fought law against the
United States he kind of gave us an
indication back in 1998 what was in
store for us and you know that
manifested itself in later on in the
attacks the I will say this referenced
the question you asked one of the one of
the problems that we have as people will
ask and they'll ask the intelligence
community for example about the Muslim
Brotherhood the Muslim Brotherhood
you've got to be careful because it
means a different thing depending on
which country you are talking about or a
region for example I'm not going to make
light because I'm know I'm being taped
but it's it's like saying that all
Republicans are the same or all
Democrats are the same you got to be
careful because all Muslim Brotherhood
are not the same so there are you know
certainly folks out there in the
different countries that
pay more attention to than others but
we've got to be careful about a
generalization if you would and so you
know currently going to the second part
your questions that are on the Libya you
know we're following the events they're
almost on an hour-by-hour basis in terms
of doing that and so at the current time
of course I don't see Libya presenting a
threat to the United States and I think
that goes without saying but you know
might they have been before that's a
another discussion we could have sir
thank you I have more of a philosophical
strategic type question how much
thinking or is it going on now or has it
happened at all about what it's going to
be the definition of victory and and
then obviously backward planning from
that to determine you know if you do XYZ
you win any thoughts on that well you
know from from a military perspective I
don't reside in the policy world any
longer you know in my current position
but one of the things that people always
take a look at on the policy side and on
the military side but as you do what we
would call in the military campaign
planning you take a look and you put it
in a format of what we would call ways
means and ends and the ways or how you
go about doing something the means or
what are you going to use to accomplish
that and of course then the ends what is
an N state what is the in-state defining
an in-state is difficult because there
are different ways to get at it and you
know as I jokingly say in public when I
speak and I don't mean it in at right
way we're in nations separated by a
common language english and words mean
different things to different people and
people want to parse words all the time
on that but but an n state is is
generally articulated if you will in a
in a campaign plan and it is something
they
over time I think moves depending on the
situation in the circumstances that play
out but it is something that from a
military perspective we always go into a
campaign or operation attempting to
define what the end state will be and
then it's up to our you know masters to
determine whether they agree with that
or not sir thank you for your service so
understanding the climate of the day and
we're facing 911 do you think that our
Defense Intelligence Agency ought to
back up and focus on our country I know
we're focusing internationally but we
have wide open borders and North and
South should we back up and focus on the
attackers that 911 were from within you
know I from a dia perspective not
necessarily I will answer your question
than speaking as a representative as a
member of the United States intelligence
community I think you know folks learned
some some very hard lessons as I
referenced in my my remarks some of the
lessons that we learn brought about a
change in this nation that manifested
itself in the passage of the
intelligence reform terrorism prevention
act of two thousand four era for short
has some have called it and that law
brought about a change most significant
change that was brought about by the law
was the establishment of a director of
national intelligence to oversee this
thing we as a nation call the United
States intelligence community and I
think there has been a lot of good that
has come out of that but from a defense
perspective my focus generally when I'm
saying that in this audience generally
is from the board
out because from the very first days for
y'all you know Hillsdale studies as you
go back and take a look our nation has
been protected by not only one the
military doing things inside our own
borders but to not just military but
others gathering information or
intelligence on those inside our borders
for good reason having said that we have
agencies inside our system that are
charged with that type of work I want to
be careful to make sure nobody goes
screaming out of here talking about an
internal security service like I've seen
in other countries that's not what I'm
talking about I'm talking about law
enforcement and so what folks have to do
but there's always a rub and when I
talked to audiences and I speak to a lot
of audiences around college campuses and
in many other places you know that's a
fair discussion for a democracy to have
at what point in time does security and
requirements to protect the nation when
it starts rubbing up against our civil
liberties where is that line and where
should it move to I'm not taking a
stance one way or the other that's a
legitimate discussion for a democracy to
have and and see where we go and I think
that's one of the things that this
school does very well ma'am it sounded
like you said
well i think you know if if the super if
you know the group isn't it doesn't come
to some sort of agreement and there's a
cut made at the end of the day i am
going to see some cut in resources
doesn't matter whether the group comes
to agreement or not i think as we look
if I step back taking my hat off as the
director of dia and just looking at it
like everybody else there have got to be
some changes made and so I'm going to
see some reduction in resources well
that's the reason I get paid the big
bucks you know it's like every other
person in a senior leadership position I
am going to have to assess risk make
sure my bosses understand where I am
accepting risk on their behalf and then
me along with my leadership will have to
manage that risk and i know i used a lot
of terms there to walk me through but
but the fact is at the end of the day i
believe for the mission that i have been
given my assessment as i've looked at it
right now i have enough resources
depending on how far a cut goes i might
not be saying it quite with such a big
smile on my face but at the end of the
day i will then have to take a look and
deal with the resources that I've been
given to do the mission and let folks
know what I will and won't be able to do
but I think as I've played in the
process so far unless things really go
in a different direction than what i
have been briefed on i think i will have
reasonable resources to do the mission
that I've been given sir however
analyst of about your generation I'm
confused by some some information I'm
hearing about the new generation of
analysts that are working in the
military such things as pattern of life
analysts and social network analysts I'm
wondering from the academic standpoint
could you go a little bit further in
telling people who represent Hillsdale
and other universities if there are
shifts in the way that we should prepare
students for these new types of analysis
I'm not sure I would say that you know
we ought to be preparing folks any
differently i will tell you that as I
step back and take a look now from my
days in the Director of National
Intelligence and and now in the DIA
Defense Intelligence Agency in the look
you know clearly we need folks you know
academia generally calls them in some
cases anthropologist you know we we
really do need people that understand
cultures as we get into and have been
doing that the fight that really
requires a lot of understanding of
tribal distinctions and down at group
level which is not necessarily a skill
set that many of us I mean you know you
know as mentioned I'm in 1974 proud
graduate of Auburn University you know
when I was a political science major
with a double minor in history and you
know not sure that helped me a whole lot
here as I was getting into some of this
a little bit so whether it be you know
understanding that the baseline cultures
and the effects thereof but but also
foreign languages I mean you know one of
the things that we don't do well you
know one of the things I'm charged to do
as an example you know it's trying to
take a look because you we don't grow
linguist overnight it takes a while in
some of these languages and dialects are
pretty hard on some of it and so you
know to get somebody through the
pipeline and all or to recruit
student I ought to be predicting what
languages i'm going to need you know I
tell I tell the story and I can I can
say this and say this in public so you
know I tell the story you know I'm
sitting there minding my own business is
the j two of us southern command and we
stand up guantanamo bay and so I'm
required to get folks in to speak
different languages and I'm sitting
there and I'm going through the list of
the languages will need you know all of
them are kind of registering even to a
guy from Auburn you know what part of
the world they're from as I go through
it War Eagle sir thank you but then I
get to this one that I even mispronounce
the first time you know but it's weger
and it's a dialect out of a you know
central part of Asia there we don't have
many of those inside the department
defense and you're not going to create
one by sending somebody to an emerging
course in six weeks to do the kind of
job we're doing so you know I need to be
predictive in where I'm going to need
somebody so that the pipeline will
produce something so you know I've got
to help more on this let's take another
example the sub-continent of India has
an example 600 plus dialects from that
one country just to have somebody to
engage with I mean you know this is
tough this is tough work so go for it
academia give it your best shot sir
general I appreciate your time my
question is the recent downgrade and
NASA what challenges given the total
source of information what challenges
you see over the next 40 50 years that
presents to the intelligence community
thank you yeah you know clearly you know
as they look at some of the things that
they're they're looking at that you've
you've alluded to is going to have an
impact you know we're going to have to
take a look as an intelligence community
for the United States of how we will
fill in some of the areas where we might
have some concerns in in terms of some
of that as it goes ahead
but you know looking at the way ahead
whether it be NASA in terms of doing it
or somebody else doing it there are
going to be certain capabilities that
we're going to require and no one in the
intelligence community is going to tell
you that we're you know ecstatic with
with things like that because just like
a commander I have yet to run into a
policymaker I've yet to run into a
commander on the ground that has ever in
my you know they keep saying 40 but to
be fair you know I'm going on 38 years
service but you know I'll take every
year I can get but i have yet in my time
to ever run into anybody that I'm doing
a brief to at any level as i'm doing the
intelligence briefing to say oh stop
stop Ron I've got enough until you don't
need to give me any more I've got all
the intelligence I need it's just not
the way it works so it'll have an impact
we as the system will have to figure out
how to mitigate that sir because I was a
career fighter pilot I was also a
defense collectors in yet can you brief
doing this yes sir I can shoot I can
shoot my watch down there you go look
and now we work for one of those other
three-letter agencies my perspective
because is a tactical and strategic one
from the tactical level a lot of the
work that I see the work that I do with
the nation-building part of it that's
relevant to the intelligence community's
they were working with especially in
Afghanistan and Iraq the tactical level
of success is working very very well
when we're working across the tables
with others that are thirsty for who we
are and what we do we find great success
from a strategic sense though my vision
is that working this thing from the top
down through Maliki and through Karzai
is well maybe it helps us understand
this definition of victory could you
comment on it well sir what I would say
good one first of all I agree with your
premise in terms of the
tactical level at the pointy end of the
spear as i call it things are working
very well both inside our own u.s.
interagency piece which has not always
to be fair been our history on this but
i think things are working very very
well down at that level right now and i
think with our our friends around the
world at that level it's working well at
the strategic level as you've talked
about i would not disagree that there
are challenges that are out there as i
talked to our military commanders and
our interlocutors inside the department
I think you know we we have an
engagement strategy with them we are
working that I tend to remind audiences
you know from time to time again
remember I don't have a Hillsdale
education I've got an auburn education
and so I still remember one of the first
basic premises that I had in political
science 201 that applies across the
board when we're talking about this and
that is a nation-state will always act
in what it deems its own national
interest that's pretty much been a given
principle throughout time in terms of
that and so we I think need to ensure
that as we have this discussion whoever
it may be around the world in at
whatever level that we have to keep in
mind of how to ensure that while we
represent our side at the end of the day
there are always at least you know one
other input and generally speaking two
or three or four especially in the
coalition world that we live today and
that's just going to be the way things
work sir one question sir would you ask
to meet the total number of al Qaeda
operatives in the world our affiliates
our supporters and just characterize
that versus the number of people we have
opposing yeah here's what I will do no i
won't give a number in here and here's
the reason why i learned a hard lesson
and I do tell this story in public and
I'll give you an idea so y'all can sit
there and take your pot shot at the the
Intel guys I used I was one of the jobs
that I had in my past I was the j2 on
the Joint Chiefs of Staff so I served as
the primary intelligence advisor to the
chairman into the secretary on the Joint
Chiefs and so you know i came into that
job in 2003 and i still remember
dutifully you know doing my intelligence
briefing you know to not only them but
to the hill and so you just as money and
so i was asked in Iraq you know how many
folks are we fighting in there so in
2003 sir we're out there and it's about
twelve to eighteen thousand two thousand
four sir about twelve to eighteen
thousand two thousand five I left the
job in 2005 sir about twelve to eighteen
thousand now you can do the math figure
out how many had we killed how many were
incarcerated and yet i'm still briefing
twelve to eighteen thousand i'm very
careful with my annals and it has
nothing to do about not wanting to get
into classified numbers I don't put a
lot of stock in finite numbers in terms
of that because you know I'm not even
sure I have a good assessment in terms
of one that I would bet my stars on
we've we've gotten numbers we roll
around but when I do the briefing to one
of my bosses I'm real careful about the
fidelity of that information and what I
put behind it so I think the numbers if
you look at al Qaeda pure
and what we would call pure al-qaeda and
what I might define it here's where we
get into we're separated by a common
language what you may mean what I may
mean by an operative per se you know the
number is not as great as some people
would believe it is in terms of
operatives when you add in the affiliate
groups AQAP AQIM al Qaeda in the Maghreb
primarily located in there in the north
part of Africa and then some other
affiliated type organizations wannabes
al Qaeda in Iraq and others the number
does move up but depending on our
definition of operative we would
probably be in a different place but
bottom line is al Qaeda and its
affiliates still are a threat and I
think an important threat to this
country that we need to deal with ok I
was going to say you got seven minutes
thank you very much general Burgess we
much appreciate your time and your
service and for all of those good
insights